good morning it is 1002 we're gonna get
started special committee on housing I'm
gonna get started with the Pledge of
Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty
okay so the reason why I wanted the
committee to get together
um right the last week of June is to
pretty much hash out
um give everybody a task uh while we're
on break and form small subcommittees on
some of these issues we've been looking
at so that we can get concrete language
for the first week of September
so
um everybody should have uh this memo
that Kristen grant our researcher put
together regarding
um kind of the things that we've
identified as impediments to Housing
Development and some things over the
six months of research that we've come
up with so I kind of want to go down one
by one and either if there's a need for
a subcommittee or if the committee
thinks that you know one person can
tackle a language on this and can
present their language at the next
meeting that works too
um definitely if there is a need for a
subcommittee I'm happy to appoint a
chair the only thing is that the meeting
needs to be noticed 24 hours in advance
and just being conquered I'll work on
getting permission from the speaker and
if there needs to be an exception to
meet during break but if not the last
the last half of August also works times
for the subcommittee to meet on concrete
language
are there any questions on that good
okay and then
um the one thing is because there's no
specific bill yet you're welcome to file
an amendment onto another bill and work
work from that or
um file a placeholder with OLS and they
can start drafting your language I
believe the the window is only four days
but if we file the legislation we can
just file a placeholder and get language
afterwards good morning
morning Mark
okay so the first thing we're going to
go down is um accessory dwelling unit so
I'm going to kick this off to
representative Reed and representative
Reed first I'd love for you to go over
kind of your language and then if if you
think there needs to be a subcommittee
or if
yeah I'm Gonna Leave This up to you okay
oh thank you all right thank you Mr
chair uh and first of all um let me just
uh notice the committee and you now that
I will be leaving for a summer job in
Alaska in two weeks I'm captaining a
whale watch vessel and so uh I won't be
available until October which means I
would have to refile
before I would be available to meet in
person again but I'm happy to work with
people over Zoom I'll have time to do
all of that so um but saying having said
that let's see if we can get as much on
the language done
um today so as you know as the committee
knows the purpose of hb423 which was
tabled this year
was to expand our current uh buy right
one Adu that towns cannot take away from
homeowners to two and also increase
um the size uh limitations that that
towns are not allowed that's weird
triple negative wording but um towns
would not be allowed to restrict it
underneath a certain size and also
increase the definition of attached so
that uh more different kinds of adus
would be permitted by homeowners by the
towns for homeowners so the amendment
that is before you right now
um so I'm just going to walk through the
different sections I realize that it's
you know a couple pages long but if you
just would bear with me and I'm happy to
like if people have comments or
questions in the middle of it we can we
can do that
um starting with the first paragraph the
definition of accessory dwelling unit
originally it was defined just as
something that was physically attached
to the primary structure we are saying
that it's anything on the lot itself and
then going on further to Define what
attached is and detached so that's where
that strike is on line six and then the
new language then paragraph Roman
numeral two attached
it there it sorry
this one's mine
perfect
uh paragraph two defines attached
um because we had gone back and forth
with wording this actually needs to be
cleaned up so it says shall also but it
should just say shall include and then
say in addition to units sharing a wall
or directly attached to the primary
dwelling shall include units that are
within or physically connected to a
primary single family dwelling or
completely contained oh I'm sorry it
does say that within or physically
connected to the primary single
family dwelling or completely contained
within a pre-existing detached structure
so we just need to strike the word also
because it's a little bit
confusing so what that's saying is if
someone has a detached garage or shed or
what have you that's already been
approved by the town it was already
built it already has the existing
footprint it's not adding anything in
terms of footprint to
um to building if you put an Adu within
completely contained within that
pre-existing structure because the town
already approved that structure to be
built
foreign
limitation that most towns prevent most
towns do not allow people to put an Adu
within a detached structure
and then it defines detached as
something that is completely new
completely separate
yes
so since you said we could ask questions
a long time yeah it seems more efficient
to me
um
just to be clear that I'm understanding
this correctly in Roman numeral 3 when
you define detached and you use the
example of an existing garage
and if a property owner wants to build a
separate
detached building on that same lot is
that included in this definition can you
say that one more time I'm sorry sure so
in Roman numeral three if a property
owner wants to build you're right a
detached unit on that same lot it
doesn't have to just be a pre-existing
building correct detached does not
include pre-existing building so so
go ahead I thought your example of the
existing garage
that would be an attached Adu we're
excited it's not actually attacked
correct because that was the
interpretation that most towns are
taking
um right now a town can limit a detached
Adu completely even if you're not
building any new structure so I had
constituents this is actually how I got
involved with the Adu conversation to
begin with I had a constituent who
wanted to build an apartment within his
detached garage for his mother-in-law
had Acres had you know beautiful
farmland and in town absolutely
prevented him even though just to pass
by it wouldn't change the rural
character you would never know that his
mother was living in the garage but the
town prevented him which I didn't think
was reasonable especially in our housing
situation that was several years ago so
the housing Situation's gotten much
worse so detached will now be only
something that has been built
specifically as an Adu not attached to
thank you for having me clarify that
um so now we get into uh starting with
line 16 this is all existing RSA except
for the Bold so on line 19 we're
striking one and saying two accessory
dwelling units will be allowed without
additional requirement except as
described later on we have and these are
things that the committee can decide but
um that I kind of put forward is what I
think maybe might be a happy balance
between all all interested parties
including the municipal Association
um so and and all but it says describing
this section setbacks aesthetic
requirements design review requirements
so basically no additional requirements
for adus except what will be described
in just a second
the municipality is not required to
allow more than two units for any single
family dwelling so they can they could
allow three or more adus but we're
saying you have to at least allow two
um and I think this helps a lot of
people because what that means is that
you could have an in-law suite for your
aging parents or for your adult children
or what have you and still have a unit
that you could rent out and add supply
to the the market
the rest is uh existing language it's
important to note here that uh adus are
not it goes in to talk about things
attached to townhouses or manufactured
homes or Condominiums and that because
there was a question in the municipal
committee well can you have an Adu onto
a duplex and according to the the
existing RSA which I tried to point out
no you cannot
if a zoning ordinance contains no
Provisions pertaining to accessory
dwelling units then two accessory
dwelling units shall be deemed a
permanent new success or a permitted
accessory use as a matter of right so
that just kind of continues
[Music]
for a test so this is the next page
paragraph three for attached dwelling
units an interior door the previous uh
wording was shall I spoke with two Town
planners when I drafted the original
bill they didn't really understand why
it was necessary to give an interior
door that would connect especially if
we're now allowing detached adus as a
matter of right as well so we thought
rather than striking it out just change
representative color
um why didn't you just write this whole
paragraph because once you do a tat a
that definition
um
is it more expansive than the principal
dwelling unit like the garage isn't
technically the principal dwelling unit
so if they could require an interior
door between the accessory dwelling unit
and the
um principle dwelling unit then they've
essentially nullified your change for
detached so just within a existing
structure no I agree with you but just
so this is an amendment to my original
bill and I had a strategic reason
because the more you change in current
RSA the less likely they're going to
accept it and so I wanted to change as
little as possible so rather than
striking the entire paragraph I just
stroke struck shall and changed it to
may but may in this sentence does not
mean the town has a right to require it
it just says it may be provided but it
doesn't say the town may require it
it's a meaningless statement at this
point it literally does not say anything
it's just like maybe there's a door we
don't know but it does not allow the
town to require the door
and I'm happy to strike it
but the reason I didn't strike it
already was to minimize the number of
representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair uh just as a matter
of History I believe I was I was here
when this was adopted in 2013 if I'm not
mistaken uh the reason it says shall an
interior door shall be provided between
the principal dwelling unit Etc is
because the whole concept of adus was
never intended for people in
single-family neighborhoods to get into
the rental business the whole purpose of
this this chapter was to allow what it
is an accessory dwelling unit for your
your aging parents your kids etc etc
that's why it said shell that was a big
sticking point when the bill was
originally passed thank you thank you no
thank you representative for that um
institutional memory that I even find
now with this being my seventh year
there's so much institutional memory I
have compared to like maybe uh
two-thirds of the the people who have
been elected since I was originally so I
appreciate that history a lot
um the purpose of my my bill hb423 this
year is to increase the opportunities
for homeowners to enter the rental
market and become landlords be because
several fold a primarily it helps people
buy homes if they can have a revenue
stream off of that home B it provides
extra housing supply to the market and
see I think if we have a market where
investment landlords have completely
controlled rental units in the prices
and the quality of rental units it's
essentially a type of Monopoly whereas
if you have these kind of I would call
Mom and Pop landlords who aren't making
millions of dollars off of rinsing out
units but just are basically helping to
fray their own mortgage then there's
going to be a lot more good faith in
that process a lot less gouging and
predatory behavior
amongst those types of landlords so that
is in fact the the purpose of my
original bill so let me let me ask
representative Walsh on the first page
line 29 it's paragraph two if a zoning
audience contains no Provisions
pertaining to adus then two shall be
deemed permanent necessary there's
nothing technically stopping a local
municipality from zoning in a
single-family neighborhood and saying no
adus are allowed here right I mean
that's the way I that's the way I read
it so I see it as kind of like not
really mattering or can you explain that
a lot of it was passed in 2013 said that
municipalities could not ban adus
um this is just merely an expansion of
it to a direction it was not intended to
be this like she like we said allows
people to get into the rental business
uh in in single-family neighborhoods uh
that's I'm just explaining what was what
we have and what this is trying to do is
completely different but but the bill
that passed in 2013 it became law
Allowed adus by rate
and so that's where it is right now as
far as I know okay
one Adu by right
the chair brings up a really good I'm
sorry I didn't get recognized
thank you the chair brings up a very
good point which was that was troubling
language to me because my understanding
was that
one Adu is provided by right and so I
wasn't clear on how to interpret that
paragraph that you just quoted so
um and if anyone has any clarifying
interpretation as to how that doesn't
mean that a town can prevent adus
completely which is what I understand is
not the case then I would like to hear
it well are you I mean are you okay with
striking or changing that from two back
to one and we'll just expand or is that
the whole point that's the whole point
of the bill I I almost want to suggest
striking lines that whole paragraph
you can continue representative okay
um I think representative I thought
representative De Lorenzo's hand was up
earlier but I don't know if she forgot
what is the purpose of the door between
the two units
I think that might be a better question
for representative Walsh since he seemed
to remember the reason that they put
that in to begin with because I am fine
with getting rid of that well I did get
rid of it in the bill
um and I'm fine with striking that
entire paragraph entirely and saying
that it doesn't really matter whether
you put a door between the two units or
not
thank you
if I may as I said the original intent
of this law when it was adopted in 2013
I believe it was not too for people to
get into the rental business it was to
allow for family members a an accessory
dwelling unit and that's the reason for
the door
uh so as soon as you detach it or take
the door away now you have Apartments I
mean that was it was for pretty much
intended for expansion uses for family
thank you thank you representative Reed
hi thank you I will say that given the
choice like we all know that we need
like 60 000 units uh built and given the
choice between a cute little garage
apartment here and a little expansion
because let's be very honest it's not
like every homeowner is going to all of
a sudden tomorrow the day after it's
signed build an Adu but this is I think
in Committee in the hearing we refer to
it as gentle density it really is the
gentlest of density and people given the
choice because we know we have like
nimbies we've said it in this committee
before but given the choice between a
massive project and this gentle density
where there's a little tucked in
apartment that you probably can't see
from the road anyway here and there they
would much rather have that and I know
that most of the tenants would rather
have that because that's usually a
better relationship with your landlord
better amenities and usually a fair
price
representative
so I want to go back to your question
about
um
um how if a
uh if a zoning ordinance
um
how is this actually a requirement that
there's there would be um accessory
dwellings I would point you to
um
chat uh line 16 and 17 on page one it
says a municipality that adopts a zoning
ordinance pursuant to the authority
granted in this chapter shall allow
accessory dwelling units as a matter of
right and so Roman 2 is only if they
have not gotcha except uh done the um
Provisions or said in their zoning
ordinance it's allowed by right then it
would default to they have a right way
thank you for for that clarification
that I was asking for earlier I
appreciate that representative
um if there's no further questions or
comments okay so moving on on page two
with paragraph Roman numeral four any
Municipal regulation applicable to a
single family drawing shall also apply
to the combination of a principal
dwelling unit in the accessory dwelling
unit including but not limited to lot
coverage standards and standards for
maximum occupancy per bedroom consistent
with the policy provided that such
Municipal regulations shall not be more
restrictive for adus than for the
principal dwelling unit so the town
can't come up with their own ordinances
specific to adus that would prevent
somebody who has all those regular
ordinances apply to the house but then
they would have additional ordinances
for the Adu the municipality may require
adequate parking to accommodate an
accessory dwelling unit but shall not
require more than one parking space per
accessory dwelling unit on the lot this
is something that has been brought up in
this committee a few times I took a stab
by saying one
um space per Adu but I'm open to what uh
the committee members think of this and
also whether or not they want to specify
off-road or on-road parking
um whether we want to say a town cannot
restrict based on parking spots at all
or whether we want to have more parking
spots per Adu as I'm sure that the
um I'm gonna just speak for myself I
would prefer if you do
um shall not require more than one
off-road parking per bedroom per Adu or
or more than one and it may be off-road
right no it well no oh it has to be yeah
it shall not require more than one
per bedroom per bedroom
so I would allow for street parking or
whatever okay
I don't know how the committee feels
representative
thank you if you would just inform me
why the preference for that parking
space being off-road well it just it
would designate it would designate only
one off-road I I guess like they could
they can require two but
can we one only one can be off-road I
wasn't questioning about the number of
parking spaces at the moment
but about specifying on-road versus
to me the issue is simply there needs to
be adequate parking I don't think it
matters a whole lot whether it's on or
off road
probably matters in the winter but that
matters no matter what
representative Walsh and representative
Reed
yeah thank you again Mr chairman I
believe this came up because uh it was
stated that some towns or something
municipalities were actually insisting
on six or eight parking spaces for an
Adu as a way to get around the ordinance
because the current rules current law
says adequate so that's pretty
subjective in towns were taking
advantage of the word adequate and
overdoing it oh complete reversal from
that statement I think after seeing or
being involved in planning for 12 years
I think one
is too little
I think that would be problematic
especially because some of these things
are getting on the larger side we're
going up to a thousand square feet which
accommodate two bedrooms very easily
um actually that's a ranch so yeah it
could be three bedrooms unless it's
unless it says otherwise so I I would
not be in favor of the one parking uh
whether it's on-site or off-site one per
bedroom would you
that would be more fair
uh Mr chair
um so how do we feel about splitting the
baby between the current language and
what the chair has suggested and say one
parking spot per bedroom and one of
those must be off-road
so one off-road per Adu and for every
extra bedroom one spot that may be
I think you're
I think just saying
um one parking spot per bedroom like
obviously I prefer no parking spot
requirements but
um one parking spot per bedroom
um
I think is uh
one it takes up less room in the and is
less confusing to the members
and uh also
I as we're discussing it if you're
limiting
um saying oh you can only have one
off-road but you don't say anything
about on-road then maybe they require 10
spaces on road and one space off-road
and technically they're still in Rec in
in compliance or something like that and
so I don't want to create those
loopholes and so if you just say one
parking space per per bedroom then they
can't get around that by saying okay you
need one off-road and one on-road for
every bedroom no no no not one office so
just to be clear my personal preference
is nothing like the town cannot restrict
based on parking at all I put this in as
a step forward towards what I presume
the municipal Association and others
with a similar mindset would want
um so the what I I didn't understand the
loophole you were describing but what
I'm suggesting is if one per bedroom and
I would like to say I kind of think one
per bedroom is too onerous because if
you have multiple bedrooms most likely
what's happening in that situation is
children who don't need a car right like
you know your eight-year-old doesn't
need a car so I think if you had a two
bedroom or three bedroom requiring two
or three parking spots is too onerous
having said that if you did one per
bedroom at all then I think it's only
fair to allow some of those to be
off-road and only require one on sorry
allow some of those to be on-road and
only require one of those for the entire
thank you Mr chairman I I would be in
favor of one parking space per bedroom I
I just went through this process into
town to add employee housing and one and
one space is I think should be in there
and if if a developer feels that that is
onerous to them they can always go
through an appeal process and and come
up with congregate parking spaces which
is what we do in my area in villages so
I won't support open end but I will
support one parking space per bedroom
representable yeah thank you Mr chair
and this is something which probably
should be checked into uh typically and
again we keep talking off-road on-road
it's actually on-site off-site
um I believe
I don't believe you can count off-site
parking if you're going to try to do
something like this you should be
looking at specifically what is required
on site as a maximum to prohibit
municipalities from trying to overuse
the word adequate and make it more than
no to make it ridiculous so I mean so
just to clarify what you said a
municipality cannot require 10 off-site
parking they can only require what's on
site in approval process usually you're
dealing with on-site parking spaces
again I'm in Hooksett not Manchester I
don't know if the larger cities can
count city streets for parking for
development but I would guess no I just
think it's something needs to be checked
into okay so the language should read
shall not require more than one on-site
parking space per bedroom per unit
in life okay do you get that down
representative Reed yeah per unit per
unit no no no no not unit
shall not require more than one on-site
parking space per accessory dwelling
bedroom
because you don't want to be including
the bedrooms of the actual principal
dwelling right okay got it represent
Broody thank you Mr chairman that's what
I was going to bring up if we have an
existing host right now we're going to
put in another one bedroom unit on that
it should work the wording should be one
additional parking space
so if I have a three bedroom right now
or a four bedroom right now and I got
two or three spaces and I want to put
another unit on only one additional
parking space should be required
instead of one per bedroom
we could ask for you know if it was a
three bedroom house now and there's only
two parking spaces now
and we're going to add one more
the way we're going one bedroom that
would be four spaces
so if we're going to add a unit add one
bedroom just one additional to what's
there now so one additional on-site
parking space per unit right one
additional on-site parking space per
unit
per bedroom per unit bedroom
sticky little technicality
um a studio is considered zerobr or zero
bedroom so
when we say one packing space per why
are you sure why are you messing with
them maybe it should be one packing
space per unit
Plus
additional
and add the bedroom numbers
so how do you how do you count a studio
that's my question okay representative
thank you uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for the question uh Department of
Environmental Services considers the
studio one bedroom
so I I think we should we should stay
with just ignore that stick with it okay
representative
so with all that's been said would it
then be correct that line nine
we take out the word adequate parking or
that is we take it out and we replace it
with additional and then the definitions
that we've been floating around here I
don't think we say adequate
and additional Edition
additional parking and I really want to
Circle back around
to it is onerous and in my mind silly to
require two three parking spots per unit
because children don't drive like it the
reason and I was going to get to this
later but I might as well bring it up
now the reason I increased the size of
the adus is because right now at 750
square feet you're basically talking
about like college students single
people people don't have long-term
stable housing in something that size if
they want a dog if they want a spouse
maybe start a family they need a little
bit more room than 750 square feet so
that's why I increased and that thousand
is only for the first the one Adu any
other additional Aid you may be
restricted down to 850 in the languages
I have and we can we can talk about that
but the point is is that it's not that
much and if you have if you do happen to
have an Adu with an extra bedroom with
two bedrooms that's going to be for a
kid that's not going to be for you know
like all these like I don't even know
like maybe the town could restrict
subletting of the renter who's renting
the Adu from subletting the bedroom or
something but
um we're talking about people having
kids not you know all these adults
representative yokelo
so I think that I understand and
obviously I agree with your points but
it doesn't need to be that big we're
already moving in a good direction by
not letting them have unlimited
number of bedrooms and so I don't think
that this is the hill to die on in this
in this bill and and
um also
um just for clarification this because
we've passed all the deadlines and stuff
like this this is going to be a new bill
right and
um in it and
um I would prefer that um line six on
page one be
um not
uh located within a lot but on a lot
okay
um and I also just for
like my preference I think that
um
that it would behoove us to consider
slicing this bill into two bills
um specifically regarding the these
attached detach fix
as possibly one part of the bill and
then the increasing the
um number of adus to a separate bill
since they don't they're kind of
independent of each other and one of
them is benef
um
and both of them would help either if
either of them passed and so I just you
know if we're if we end up going into a
subcommittee or whatever I think that
the you know possibly
um dividing that or considering what
things might be able to improve like
whether the parking requirement change
and this attached detach thing might be
considered like a fix to the existing
law whereas this other thing is an
expansion
of it right and so I don't know
something to consider recognized to
respond thank you um I completely agree
with you on your first couple points and
I'm not suggesting that the parking is a
hill I'm going to die on I think uh
clarifying adequate is a step in the
right direction in any case and I
absolutely am fine with saying on
instead of Within
I'm not sure what the difference is but
I'm fine with it
um I at this point I don't see the sense
in dividing this into two bills because
I think if it if we all can get on the
same page about the entire thing and it
just it hits whatever committee maybe
this own committee with the unanimous
recommendation of this committee I think
it's a strong bill and it's dealing with
the same exact RSA so I would hate to
like parse that up and you know try to
figure out which part belongs and what
but if we are so what I think that we're
at now is to say additional instead of
adequate
and to say one on-site parking space
that they cannot require more than one
accessory dwelling unit bedroom I I'm
per Adu bedroom
representative
representative Walsh
actually I'm just once we're done with
parking I just want to bring up one more
topic before we move on is everyone okay
with that language
representative Damon we just asked the
municipal Association to weigh in on
that language I would be happy to ask Mr
thank you uh
ready
um nature Grace for the municipal
Association assuming that I've taken
notes correctly I think what the
committee is proposing is it would read
a municipality may require adequate
parking to accommodate an accessory
dwelling unit but shall not require more
than one additional on-site parking
space per bedroom per accessory dwelling
unit on the lot
that sounds right
yep
representative Damon I thought we
figured out the word adequate and put
additional where the word adequate is
not quite where you said I think it
means the same but I would say that what
I wrote in mine version which is messy a
municipality may require additional
parking to accommodate an accessory
drilling unit but shall not require more
than one on-site parking space per
accessory dwelling unit bedroom on the
lot
which I think means the same as what you
said yeah I don't think you need the on
the lot just Crush out on the lot and
just say accessory unit bedroom sure
it's okay happy to accommodate that okay
so did representative Damon did you want
Municipal Association away in on that
language
all right so
municipality may require
uh additional parking to accommodate an
accessory dwelling unit but shall not
require more than
one on-site parking space per bedroom
per accessory dwelling unit
I think that's clear that the maximum
limit
that could be in the local zoning
ordinances is one space per bedroom they
could obviously put into place something
that's less than that so the local
option would be you know if you're
building a
I don't know three bedroom accessory
dwelling unit
um they may only require two parking
spaces instead of three right that's
true so I think representative Damon
looks a little confused so we're we're
yeah and this is true of the entire all
of enabling language really any enabling
Bill gets confusing this way because
you're not saying what the town will
require you're saying they can't require
more than this so we don't want a town
to say you need 20 spaces to build an
Adu you can't say more than one per
bedroom but the town can say actually we
don't need you to prove that you've
you've got like a five Acre Farm we
don't need you to prove that you have
you know adequate parking or whatever
they if they wanted to they just can't
require more
it's the it's the upper limit yeah
um while I'm up here if I can make one
other comment also from a comment that
representative Damon made
um under the definition of detached on
page one section three there
um
it
may be
useful to include uh
the
part of the attached definition that
helps Define what is attached versus
detached so it would read something
along the lines of detached show include
units completely contained within a lot
that are not physically connected to the
primary single family dwelling or
completely contained within pre-existing
detached structures because
under attached you already have defined
everything within that right
um you know detached garage if it's
within then it would be
um considered attached you're absolutely
right Mr graze and I actually I said it
very quickly as I was going through that
and it's for clarity's sake okay
anything else thank you thank you
all right so
um
the only I I think representative
is a voice of reason and I think he's
right
I know it's going to be screened it's
gonna be clipped
um our next campaign there's some Merit
to what he says in the sense of the
heaviest lift in this bill is the one to
two and then the easier lift is the
clarifying definitions clarifying
adequate parking
um you know maybe expanding the
definition of what it looks like
attached detached but the
I I don't want to speak for other
members of the committee but I want to
say that I think the heaviest lift is
the one to two and I will say and this
is true because I do a lot of like
reform centered bills that if you reform
a thing in a small way that frequently
takes away the argument for the larger
reform and I would hate to shoot the
extension to 2A to use in the foot
because the committee goes oh well we
you know we increased um the uh the the
attached and detached and the square
footage and everything and then they're
like so we don't need to increase it to
two and I think two is extremely
important both for the housing market
and for homeowners who are looking to
buy but need that Revenue stream
um so I I that's my argument to keep
them all together and to send one very
strong Bill to the committee with the
unanimous approval of this committee
if we don't end up getting it ourselves
would you like to continue on your bill
I would love to continue on if nobody
else has anything okay okay represent
um we're just on right moving on from
parking and now we're on to paragraph
five which I don't change anything in it
just says that a town can require
adequate water and sewage systems so a
septic or what have you
that they can approve that
uh and paragraph six says municipality
may require owner occupancy of one of
the dwelling units but it shall not
specify which unit the owner must occupy
I think this is fine this is from the
original RSA that was current law
um that we're saying now there's nothing
saying that the owner then can't sell
that house that has that uh Adu but in
order to do this we're excluding
developers investment developers that
are looking to make money off of renters
we are saying you're a homeowner this is
your home you live there and you just
want to build something either for a
family member or one extra rental
income so I think that's fine the owner
occupancy requirement that currently
exists
paragraph seven if there's nothing a
municipality May establish standards for
accessory dwelling units for the purpose
of maintaining the aesthetic continuity
of the principal dwelling unit as a
single family dwelling Unit A
municipality may also establish minimum
maximum sizes for adus provided that the
size may not be restricted to less than
striking out 750 1000 square feet for
one of the units Allowed by Wright and
850 square feet for any other unit
provided that it is the primary that
provided and this is a new piece that I
did add after hearing one of the
presentations provided that if the
primary structure is a thousand square
feet or less the municipality May
restrict the accessory dwelling unit to
800 square feet so one of our presenters
and I forget who I apologize talked
about this being or an 80 rule being
something that some towns do
um saying that because you don't want
the Adu to be larger than the primary
dwelling unit or the primary structure
the primary yeah marriage dwelling unit
so that makes sense to me because then
it kind of loses the purpose of being an
Adu so I thought that was fine and we
are allowing again this is not
legislation that is saying this is what
has to happen this is legislation
allowing towns to do this so
um
so is everybody clear on what that bold
does it expands the size for the for for
all of them but a thousand for one of
the 80s Allowed by right 850 for any of
them but in any case if it's a small
house a thousand square foot house
you're not going to build an extra
thousand square foot um Adu onto that
thousand square foot house
you're going to build something that is
smaller
all right uh
paragraph eight a municipality may not
require a familial relationship between
the occupants of the accessory dwelling
unit and occupants of principal dwelling
unit this is in current RSA this is law
currently so that is I understand that
the as representative uh Walsh said that
the
um the intent of the original bill in
2013 was to extend it to family members
but in fact the law currently in that
bill actually made sure that it wasn't
limited to only family members uh nine a
municipality may not limit an accessory
drawing unit to only one bedroom
um I think the square footage
restrictions are fine and then there's
also of course those additional
ordinances that bedrooms be of a certain
size that the town may have uh 10 an
accessory dwelling unit may be deemed a
unit of Workforce housing for purposes
of satisfying the municipality's
obligation under RSA
67459 if the unit meets the Criterion
RSA
674-58 four for rental units so this is
really an important I'm going to read
the rest of it and talk about this the
municipality may require that if a
property has two
sorry
or more accessory dwelling units one of
them shall meet the criteria for the
workforce housing for rental units this
was something I worked really closely
with Mr Gray's of Municipal association
with
um this is important for two reasons
first of all if the entire purpose of
this bill as it was
um is to help the housing market then we
want to be able to meet that Workforce
housing so this allows towns without
building big projects without building
big giant apartment buildings without
these giant developments that people get
you know nimby-esque about it allows
towns to meet in a decentralized way
those
the workforce housing requirements so
and help our overall housing crisis it
also de facto because another
consideration we were worried about and
in my one of the early drafts of this
bill I had prohibited or allowed towns
to prohibit on the second unit
um short-term rentals by putting in the
workforce housing definition because
short-term rentals are so much more
expensive
um this de facto allows towns to
prohibit uh short-term rentals on uh any
any unit that they require the workforce
housing again they can only require it
on uh one of the two adus they can't
require the workforce housing rental
limit on both but they can require it on
one and for that one there is no that
would de facto prevent short-term
rentals yeah I see a hand
um representative donkey
thank you Mr chairman I would assume
that RSA
674-58 is a relatively short item and if
we could committee could get a copy of
that at some point during a break I just
want to be able to read that
right representative thank you I was
looking it up as we were talking so
um 674 58 Roman 4 reads it's the
definition section of that's uh of of
the workforce housing
um it's it says Workforce housing means
housing which is intended for sale
and which is Affordable to a household
with an income of no more than 100 of
the median income for a four-person
household for a metropolitan area or
county in which the housing is located
as published annually by the United
States of Housing and Urban Development
Workforce housing also means rental
housing which is Affordable to the
household with an income of no more than
60 percent of the median income for a
three-person household for the
metropolitan area or county in which the
housing is located as published by
annually by the United States Department
of Housing and Urban Development housing
developments that excludes minor
children for more than 20 percent of the
units in which
have more than 50 percent of the
dwelling units uh have fewer than two
bedrooms shall not constitute Workforce
housing for the purpose of the
subdivision so essentially that that
middle sentence where it's talking about
rental is what we're talking about 60
years 60 of the area median income so
sixty percent of a median income for a
okay all set mark okay could be if it
could be narrowed and I don't know that
it can to exclude the beginning where it
talks about sale of a unit because
um
I don't know if there's a point to break
in there because the word sale is going
to cause heartburn to some people where
is the word sale I mean in this bill in
You couldn't possibly sell the the um
the
accessory dwelling
separate from the
I I I understand I'd like to see it
writing just so we have it and be able
to hold it apart I think that what
you're saying is that since this
definition is all in one part that it
would almost be better to just grab that
set that middle sentence and stick it in
the bill instead of referencing the RSA
is what you're suggesting I I believe so
okay okay Helen did you get that
no
okay so
um there's a middle can you
can you modify
Workforce housing also means so can you
just read it out loud just say it out
loud so instead of saying or or
referencing RSA 674-58
Roman 4. he is suggesting that you quote
a section of that saying oh
that qualifies uh me
um it meets the
um criteria of
um affordable to a household with an
income of no more than 60 percent of the
median income for a three-person
household for a metropolitan area or
county in which the housing is located
as published annually by the United
States Department of Housing and Urban
Development period okay can you read the
part that was giving heartburn the sale
piece
yes he did well it's referencing it's
referencing the whole thing but yeah
inside of the four it says Workforce
housing means housing which is intended
for sale and which is Affordable to and
so he's trying to avoid that but you
could also just say quote uh rental we
could like just specify the rental
portion of that section well it you kind
of already did in the in the thing
uh colon
or Roman four four rental units is
already in the bill but he's saying hey
what he's thinking that it should be
more clear and just okay essentially
take that part against reference I can
get clarifying language to make sure
we're pinpointing that specific section
okay
all right
we're wrapping up we got like three more
paragraphs and we're done uh Roman
numeral 11 paragraph 11 a municipality
shall allow detached accessory dwelling
units to be cited on a lot line if the
lot line abuts a public alley unless the
municipality routinely plows snow on the
public alley this is directly out of the
missing middle uh language that a lot of
states have adopted and that I worked
with the oh my gosh what is the
University people that came
mercatus uh people this is what they
specifically yes uh specifically
suggested
um I don't know if anybody has a problem
with that but it seemed reasonable
representative McConkey today
um could I ask why it would seem
reasonable to allow a building to be
built on a lot line
if if it's not a budding another owner
but is a budding a public alley and that
Ally is not plowed
then that's why it'd be reasonable
because you're not really hurting anyone
it kind of that public alley provides
its own buffer I
yeah I'm thinking like blind spots and
corners and things like that like is
there anything that would like restrict
a municipality from
not allowing that I'm happy to strike it
it was by the cheers recommendation I
work with the mercatus center people
um and this is what they suggested and
it is um out of part of what's out of
some other State's language but I'm
happy to strike it if people find it
problematic
I think that is a good call all right
um in that case that's what I have noted
and um and when we get to the end of
this I will have OLS draft up according
to our notes today and I'll have that
sent out to everyone
um Roman numeral 12 a municipality
shallow accessory drilling units to be
converted from existing structures
include instructors including but not
limited to detached garages regardless
of whether such structure violates
current code requirements for setbacks
or lot coverage this is also from
mercatus
um it's really kind of in my mind like
extra because we already kind of said
that but I'm fine with leaving it in
I I like the language because it's like
already a building that is built on a
lot and it just like if if somebody
wants to renovate that building to make
it an Adu right it just can't be
restricted but it's already it's already
an existing structure I like that
language
representative yokella yes I would agree
with you just on the because sometimes
um
is
non-conforming structures have
additional restrictions
um
and so this is essentially saying that
you can't
um you're still you're allowed to keep
non-conforming structures and you should
be able to you know modify within them
right and so I think that the key point
is regardless of whether such structures
violate current code requirements for
setbacks yeah
um and then the final paragraph uh
originally detached accessory dwelling
units were allowed to be not permitted
um towns were allowed to prohibit them
um but we're changing that to
municipality is required to permit
detached accessory drawing units for at
least one unit Allowed by right under
this chapter but may require any other
units to be attached detached accessory
dwelling units shall comply with
requirements of and any Municipal
ordinances or regulations adopt and
pursuant to RSA 670 472 four through
nine and I did add this in my original
Bill a municip and this is based on a
couple planners recommendation a
municipality may require a property to
have a minimum lot size of up to one
half acre in order to have two or more
accessory dwelling units so that doesn't
touch our one Adu right now it doesn't
matter if you have an eighth of an acre
or whatever you can still build one Adu
what we're saying is yes that second one
is allowed by right but the town can say
you have to have a half acre for a
second one
um which I thought was reasonable
because you are adding a whole entire
second
um Adu
um but I'm happy to open that up to
discussion and see what the committee
thinks
okay so uh representative Delorenzo
let's have a general question
um about unit size and you know
requirements and is that and the
question is that have
you considered
um handicapped accessible units and I'm
asking that because I could imagine
um
doing a Adu
for with accessibility requirements for
a wheelchair person
um and then if the will the person who
uses the wheelchair needs to have
um an aid
a living Aid would any of that be
considered in the Adu bill
well I mean there
there's still like the like Ada that
well I get I get I mean does anybody
have an answer that no yeah I'd ordered
yeah I don't know if you can plan for
the future like that maybe if this
happens you know I don't think
for our purpose I don't think that would
work okay right representative yokella
um I think that uh hopefully I mean what
you're seem to be talking about is is
there enough room for such a situation
and hopefully
um
personally I think that a thousand
square feet is probably enough room to
be able to house two people
um in different rooms but
um
but also hopefully municipalities don't
as they seem to frequently just go to
the bare minimum that we put in law and
actually are more
um
allowing and so therefore if they did
not have a size requirement then it
would just be up to the the property
owner to to build the
design the thing for to meet the needs
of the people that were planning the
house right thank you thank you
okay um representative Damon then
on the half acre
um the option of municipalities
requiring that minimum lot size
depending on the municipality and
the density of the area where this might
be happening that's actually fairly
generous and therefore it is a way to
limit adus
I
inquire what people think about making
it a third or a quarter or maybe yeah
yeah that's I'm open to I have to note I
just looked at a house with one of my
daughters in one of the burbs north of
New York on Friday that was a third acre
and I was actually pretty impressed
visually see how much third of an acre
was I think I had a personally but
visual of that yeah
I did a community supported agriculture
project and like it was the whole thing
was like a quarter acre you'd be
surprised it's quite large
yeah but I'm I'm fine with reducing that
down
um but hold on one second um
representative Walsh
huh yeah I'm not even sure where to
start thank you Mr chair
um it's funny you mentioned that you
thought a half acre was generous I was
going in the opposite direction of that
of course uh because I I don't know I've
been looking at this for a long time to
be quite honest with you if it's okay I
just make a statement I do give this
stuff some thought I thought we were
going to be looking at a bill that maybe
changed the law around accessory
dwelling units to prohibit
municipalities from replacing ordinances
in place that stop them you know as
guide reels this is not just going to be
a heavy lift I don't think I can get
behind it either and and I'll tell you
why and I'm sure I'm going to get the
NIMBY labeling for this but
I own 0.8 Acres I don't but according to
this I would be able to put and it's
only it's 100 feet wide and 450 feet
deep I could put four units
in mine according to this
that's crazy but but even more than that
my neighbor has two and a half acres how
many buildings could they put up now the
reason the reason when this whole Adu
thing went into place and they were
attached
it's so people that weren't building
apartments all over their properties and
why that's a problem then and I still
think it is now again here we go with
the NIMBY labels that's fine but if we
don't speak our opinions what's the
purpose even coming here if you look at
most residential subdivisions you've got
your front set back to house which is
usually 50 feet even if they go more
than that they usually have all the
houses about the same distance off the
road so when everybody's looking at each
other's windows and looking in the other
windows they accept that people use
their backyards for their little
Serenity their little privacy they're
all they're a fence or a tree or a bush
away from having some sanity and now
what we're trying to do with this
expansion is allow one neighbor over
here or one neighbor over there to start
building buildings all the way down into
that backyard this this is crazy I
cannot see this so that's my opinion
okay representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for the
um opinion
um so first of all I need to there were
two bills that kind of were sort of
similar this year this bill and the four
Plex bill
when you say this bill would allow you
to build four units on a 0.8 acre that
that literally is untrue of this bill
completely what it would do is up to
allow you to build up to three units
um with one having to be attached to the
primary dwelling unit so that is all
this bill does the four Plex bill would
have allowed for independent units on a
property and it would have been open to
developers to do that meaning developers
would that would encourage the current
problem which is developers investment
developers buying these uh the land up
and building expensive buildings that is
the problem that is why people are being
priced out that this bill does not do
that this bill only allows an owner
occupier so they have to live there to
build an extra one extra Adu than they
already have with one of those two being
attached having to be attached so when
you say Apartments all over my property
that's is literally untrue the only
thing that you might possibly and it's
not again it's not like everybody's
going to do this tomorrow but you might
possibly see an extra building go up in
a backyard as long as it's a half acre
or more currently according to this
language but you would not see
Apartments everywhere that's that's that
is a straw man of what this bill is and
I have said this before but I will give
it to you again which is you only have
two choices we are sixty thousand units
below where we need to be for people to
not be pushed out and homeless so you
can either approve all these massive
apartment buildings that neither tenants
want nor the as you call them nimbes
would want or you can allow regular old
folk who are just working regular jobs
to have one extra apartment on their lot
if they want and that being a gentle
over a long period of time development
right representative Walsh
lion 14 page three a municipality may
require a property to have a minimum lot
size of up to one half acre in order to
have two or more accessory dwelling
units we only have 15 foot setbacks
which means on my lot according to that
statement I could build four of them
thank you
one
thank you for uh recognizing me I think
um
one of the things in this bill is that
it is setting a bar of a minimum and if
the municipality chose to allow 70
um accessory dwelling units on a
property they are allowed to do that as
a municipality this so what you're
talking about is not a requirement by
this bill that is the municipality
allowing for accessory dwelling units
that is not requirement under this bill
the accessory dwelling unit requirement
under this bill is a minimum of two and
that and so that would only make three
you're saying more that is the option
for municipalities to allow as many as
they want
and and that would be on the
municipality
um
um discretion so
um the four is just up to municipalities
four or five or seventy or however many
they want is up to their
um discretion I'd also disagree with
that um that people don't want the
um the rentals that are being built as
they are
like like completely full as soon as
someone builds them so I I don't agree
that that the bill that the rental units
being built are unpopular I'm I'm gonna
go to representative Damon
did you have your hand up
I did
um thank you
I'm not sure if what I'm thinking makes
sense so I'm just going to say it out
loud and people will help me sort it out
so in that last statement line 14 15 on
what happens
does that address representative Walsh's
concern is it a little
clearer even though it doesn't change
the intent of the bill let me let me ask
something
is there like language in this bill that
you can sign off on get behind that
would further clarify
the current edu law or is there not I
guess like I'm kind of trying to the
goal is to get everybody on board so if
there is some part of the bill you know
if
if there's something where we clarify
and then you know some of the committee
signs off on one part of the bill and
some of it signs off on another bill I'm
I'm okay with that too
um
representative Walsh
um yeah thanks Mr chair yeah again like
I said before there were certain things
I thought we could all come to uh
agreement on in terms of people trying
to sabotage the the current law I get
that and I think we should be able to do
that in terms of what you just asked me
with with line 14 I agree I was off by a
unit okay I get we but I get that it's
up to the municipalities to adopt as
many as they want however we are still
as a state with this law moving the bar
it's still going to be a tough lift yeah
okay representative Rudy thank you Mr
chairman
um what if we
um had to have
um take out the two or more units
that that would help wouldn't it
representative Reed
so I I think I'm just going to be saying
in a different way what representatives
yokella and
um Damon already said but this is not
the only place in this bill that says or
more and the reason it says or more is
because a town can allow three adus 4A
to use they can allow currently
currently they can allow as many adus as
they want the language of our current
RSA says but they have to allow one and
all I'm saying is but they have to allow
two and one of them had they can
restrict to being attached so the worst
case scenario provided a town does what
we expect that they will do which is
restricted all the way down to what
they're legally required to allow
the worst case scenario the most Urban
most apartmenty looking a property would
be a half acre lot that has an attached
Adu that's part of the primary structure
and one extra building in the back
that is the worst case scenario that is
the most oh my God they're building
apartments everywhere we're freaking out
this isn't real character anymore that's
the worst I don't think that's that bad
it looks like in a detached garage
that's all it looks like so
I think we can we have to do something
about housing that's why we exist as a
committee we have to do something so we
either keep doing what we've been doing
and more and more people will be kicked
out of the state and more and more
people will be homeless or this this is
the lowest hanging fruit you can imagine
just let homeowners build one extra
thing on their home and if you are
scared that all of a sudden tomorrow
it's going to be a free-for-all with all
these adus we currently allow 1adu how
one last thing
that is my point that currently the
municipalities can do or approve as many
of them as they want they just haven't
done it yet in 11 years imagine that and
now we're telling them we're proposing
to tell them that now they have to thank
you
so I
thank you Mr chairman of all my years in
excess of seven
um I have a
I've delved in a committee Public Works
and highways where a level of passion
never rises above and beyond asphalt and
concrete prices
I have prided myself have being part of
a committee that reaches consensus or we
don't move forward
so the way other people conduct their
business and their committees is what
they are I'd like to keep this back to a
level of not condescending but trying to
work in cooperation
I think I think that Anne Moore would
make me happy to be out of there because
towns can always do or municipalities
can always do more if they choose to I
think when you I think when you get to
that line if it were to stay
municipality may require a property of
minimum lot size of up to one half acre
or to have
up to two cessary dwelling units but you
might you might want to key it back to
providing
it meets the requirements there's a
requirement in here from
Section 5 that talks about disposal of
sewage unless it's a municipality that
has water and sewer
you're never you're never going to
permit
two accessory units to be on a lot
that's less than a half an acre it just
doesn't happen
so I I think you need to tie that back
you say it either with with Municipal
Water and Sewer or just say per the
requirements of number five because in
my neck of the woods where we don't have
water and sewer that you're you're
giving a glimmer of hope to a developer
that they can never get to so if the
goal is to get through this through
today so that we can have an individual
bill then I say nay if we're going to
work on it I'm happy to work on it
okay
representative Reed thank you Mr chair
um so right now this is the most
restrictive form of what you're saying
what you're suggesting would actually
make it less restrictive we're saying
currently the town can require a half
acre and in addition the water
restrictions the sewage restrictions
we're saying a town can require both if
you take out the half acre and tie it
back to five then what you're saying is
there's only the sewage restrictions so
this is the more restrictive version
right here
um I want to go back to the original
comment made about passion and
the supposed definition of Civility so I
understand that people of different
Generations May perceive how especially
some Sexes Express themselves as being
maybe out of what they expect no I'm
representing I am
I'm just going to ask you ask you my
point was that the original passion that
I saw was someone a member calling this
bill ridiculous and saying
I I we're trying we're trying to get to
a consensus Here Right Moving us away
from that but my passion is with making
sure that people are not kicked out of
where they live kicked out of the state
and kicked out of having housing at all
okay so I think I do understand that and
I understand his passion on both sides I
or all sides I guess
we've been at this for an hour and 15
minutes is there a way for us to
maybe send language to representative
Reed that would get you to a yes on this
bill
Crossing things out making changes
um this
it can't be to the entire committee it
can be one-on-one sent
um I guess I'm kind of wondering how the
committee wants to move forward we have
a couple other things to talk about
okay representative yokella
um I think that
the language obviously the language that
we've talked about thus far and the
changes that we've talked about thus far
um
I support all of them and so I don't
feel the need to submit anything
necessarily to representative Reed but I
definitely do think that there are
things potentially within this bill that
other members may have that we've talked
about that may have issues with and so
those members I think could reach out to
representative Reed and that would
impress upon her what I was previously
stating as the benefit of having two
bills and that you could get one of them
with unanimous support and one of them
with majority support potentially
that's what I was thinking
representative Reed thank you and if it
turns out that this committee cannot get
behind one strong bill which is what I
said was the intent the reason I thought
it was good to have one bill is to have
one strong bill that the entire
committee supported if that turns out to
be impossible then it makes a lot more
sense to separate it out having said
that everything we've been through so
far every point we seem to move on from
without any
um problems until we got to this very
last sentence and the two
recommendations I heard about this very
lesson well there's three there was one
saying bring it down to a like a quarter
or a third of an acre but then the other
that's moving in the opposite direction
of what some of the concerns of the the
other members are one was to get rid of
it entirely I'm open to that the other
one was to just get rid of or more and
I'm open to that as well I don't think
either one changes the overall meaning
at all except for to get rid of
completely half acre requirement but
that makes it less restrictive so I if
if the committee wants to vote on which
version of that right now or just kind
of unofficially vote uh straw poll which
version I'm happy to accept whatever the
committee says and put that in a draft
so let me
let me ask so I I think there is there's
a heavy lift Bill and then there's kind
of like a low-hanging fruit bill
like from what I'm seeing
um and you might you might get
you know unanimous on one and maybe be
half on the other
representative Walsh if I'm
understanding you right
if we keep it just 180u
limit the parking language that we put
out there and then
attached and detached
is in the square footage
is that language that we talked about
okay with you and then the second the
other bill would be making it one to two
and then
the second one could be required as
stuff yeah thank you Mr chair before I
answer you I do apologize for my
passionate comments I don't get a chance
on Transportation too often either
um
I guess why I have a hard time with such
uh to answer your question first yes I
think now after this debate it would
make sense to separate the easy from the
difficult lists and again I think the
easy lift is just to re you know make
sure the municipalities are passing
ordinance to just get around the whole
step
um get around the whole statute
um but I guess I just in general in
terms of why I may have a passion for
this I I just I don't look at the local
planning boards and zoning boards as
being always nefarious for the reasons
they do things uh and so when I see us
trying to push back on that there's all
we don't know the situations on anything
that goes on and we're still trying to
Edge away a little more of the
decision-making of the people that
actually live there that's why I have
the passion I do about these discussions
But to answer your question we should
separate if so to clarify if we separate
just now
is that something where if I mean
obviously you have to see language but
if we split it up from expanding it from
one to two and adding a Workforce
housing that would be like a different
bill and the other one would be attached
detached parking clarifications and then
um
square foot requirements
I'd like to see the language but I think
that's a direction to go that would be
more productive okay so the other one I
have a fear of the setbacks too
but again that's all in that same that
first bill that easier lift Bill okay so
we have flexibility we have time on this
so
um what I'm going to ask representative
Reed I know this is not obviously what
you want I mean I
personally am in favor of both but
I want to get a consensus from everybody
on lease one so can you work on this and
then send us language for two different
bills with the uh chairs blessing I will
prepare both separate uh bills as well
as one combined bill in case we can get
to consensus on the combined because I
do fear very much that despite the
increase to two adus having broad
support across both parties and across
multiple organizations
that if we separate it out separately we
are shooting it in the foot so I would
like to propose or prepare three
different bills okay and there have been
a lot of edits to the one that we have
here today so I'd like to see that
language too I have all of that
um I just still have the question of
what people want me to do with the last
sentence here
is it is it fine the way it is or would
representative Damon
so if we strike that last statement
entirely
then that
doesn't change existing law
in any municipality so they in fact
could correct me if I'm wrong here could
still have a minimum lot size
no representative yeah go ahead
yep so thank you
um so right now we're only allowing them
to do certain certain types of uh
restrictions on Accessory dwelling units
which it includes like setbacks and
aesthetic and design review and stuff
like that and and Frontage but we're not
allowing them to set size requirements
um for those adus so the first Adu could
be added as long as there was space
right now there this this language is
essentially trying to
empower the municipality that if there
was going to be two that they could set
a minimum floor for that lot requirement
whereas right now they're not they're
not able to do that
is
prohibits a municipality from putting a
minimum lot size on RSA on paid to use
go ahead represent no but currently the
1ad Allowed by right is allowed by right
without any additional requirements so
that I mean and it's actually referenced
earlier yes
uh 19 through 21 yeah um on page one
okay no additional requirements so by me
inserting this I was doing what I
thought the quote-unquote nimbies or the
municipal Association would like which
is to say okay we're not just allowing a
free-for-all you know if you're on an
eighth of an acre you have to have at
least a half an acre to have a second
Adu so if we strike it and just revert
it back to section five with just only
the sewage that is less restrictive if
you want more restrictions than you
leave it in the or more is a
technicality because
towns can allow more if they want and
that goes throughout the current RSA the
or more language but if people are
feeling very strongly about getting rid
of or more because it just freaks them
out then I'm happy to get rid of it Nate
Nate would you be able to weigh in on
this for us and I'm hoping to move on
from this so we can talk about a couple
other things and have the rest of our
afternoon
Mr chair as you as you'd like to move on
I'm certainly well happy to to work with
representative Reed to uh to work on
this language
um
as I understand it the intent here in
this I guess newly revised um 674-73
lines 10 through 15.
is to clarify that
one of the accessory dwelling units is
um
allowed to be detached by right and then
the other one could either be attached
or detached and
obviously the the municipality could
allow more than two units
um and as part of that
I think the intent is to ensure that
there's adequate
um
lot size to accommodate things like
septic sewer Wells
Etc
um
based in the committee's conversations
it appears there needs to be a little
bit more tweaking of this language I'm
happy to work on that but I don't have
any language at the moment okay
thank you thank you
representative Damon
so as a new rep here I just have a
process question
what is permitted
for conversations outside committee
for example if I want to have an
individual conversations with various
different members of the committee
that's a lot but then
the conversation with party a may come
up in the conversation with party B so
that's all fine
so we can bounce things back and forth
and we can do it by email as well as
whatever else okay I just wanted to be
sure I wasn't violating if I form a
subcommittee on this it would have to be
noticed and but if if if you want to
work on some part of specific language
representative read or any member of the
committee or certainly not to do and it
just to add on to that if you have a
meeting of your any meeting you have
zoom or otherwise with more than half a
half or more of the committee would
require a notice by 91a but less than
half is fine okay yeah so I am hoping
I'm hoping to move on from this do we
have action items on this representative
you can have it okay
I'm going to prepare three different uh
bills one two of them are separated from
this and one will be a combined based on
the notes that we've talked about today
okay
okay so I'm going to move on for number
two I'm gonna go to number three on
Demar Department of Environmental
Services
um I don't I'm sorry
okay um I am hoping that representative
McConkey would be willing to put
together some language on this stuff and
we don't need a specific subcommittee on
that
that's fine Mr chairman I think that's
pretty straightforward yeah and I
actually we were doing some research
about
um it's gallons per day usage and we're
the highest in New England I like a lot
so I kind of want to see like
is it it's it's through a rule making
process but I kind of want to see like a
way to update the legislature and you
know
identify
what rules have been in place for a
while that could be lack like lacks
things things like that lacked up to the
legislature
um
representative
thank you um Ari
are I mean I definitely I guess I would
like to
uh kind of get a sense of where we're
headed with the Environmental Services
thing because the way you described it
with 150 gallons I think that it should
be changed I wouldn't
like I don't care to get a report from
Des about we've had it for 30 years or
10 years or in two years it doesn't
really matter to me I think it should
just be changed and so
um
the so I guess the wording that you said
it seemed like give me an update of like
how often this has changed or whatever
and I'm going in a different direction
with that and so I guess where where
we're where's the committee I guess
planning I think I was splitting hairs I
think representative cocky kind of gets
a an idea of the direction that we want
to head with this stuff so I'm gonna let
him put together a language and then
um present it at our meeting at the end
of
um August first week of September on
what you came up with and if there needs
to be tweaks we can do it then
um so I want to go back to number two
um appeals of unfavorable board
decisions so we talked a little bit
about
expanding the hab but further clarifying
um appeals that can be made to the hab
so
we want to add all these other like if
if there's an unfavorable decision by
the fire department Health Department
State Fire Marshal obviously zoning
um Heritage commission a dangerous
species any of those things that those
suits or appeals can be done through the
hab so I have um Catherine Kerry Fox
here at least can you come up and
explain the language currently in the
hab and you say it's not necessarily
needed to clarify this language but
um could you give us kind of a direction
for this committee please
this is one of the issues that we
identified as a problem where people are
receiving unfavorable decisions from
local
officials and we want to make sure that
they have an Avenue to appeal that I'm
happy to assist if I can so good morning
I guess Kathy Corey Fox and I am with
the Bernstein Shore group I work with
one of the attorneys who was the former
chair of the housing appeals board and
when I heard previous discussions on
their duties and such I reached out to
Greg Michaels
and he shared with me it's RSA 679 and
uh 679 colon five spells out the duties
of the housing appeals board
and I think at that time at your meeting
a few weeks ago some of the concerns
were raised he it was his opinion that
the housing appeals board could hear
um such cases
the question did come up about I think
you would ask about this state fine
martial nose codes and he was kind of
questionable about that his comment to
me if it was part of the overall plan
possibly but again it would be have to
look at case per case
so my my request is that
um could you send us maybe some language
or something that he was working on that
he was out of town and he said he would
get me that and I haven't I will follow
up with him absolutely to present you
that would be great because I I want to
make sure that um we clarify with the
hab and then I believe was there the
land you stalk it passed as well right
that is correct so I think we would also
want to clarify it with the land you
stock it which kind of is another
mirrors the have in another it's another
Avenue right of course it is and I'm
sure representative Lynn would be more
of a resource for that with the what he
envisions so happy to do some awesome
okay anything else on this actually item
good there okay um representative
is the point so it seemed to me that
um
there was a representative
um that was most
uh impassioned about this and
um maybe should be the point person are
you planning on on putting a point
person as far as like the person to be
drafting legislation on this or are you
planning on taking that on yourself or
what
um I I have a lot of history with the
housing appeals board and Landing stock
it so I'm definitely willing to take
that on and present it to the committee
when I have the language
thank you
representative pillow
um
thank you
well I get I guess
um
it's a little bit like it's a little bit
this one is a little bit eight is my
um uh amendment that I pass around
um
if anyone doesn't have it
um it's it's Amendment HB 1313
um
it's about things that I have
um um you have
you wanna you need a copy
um
we talked a little bit about
um how
well a lot about how uh
like restrictions and how how we could
um help incentivize I
um the streamlining of processes and and
how we can
um
affect I guess municipal
um ins inspections and or make things go
more smoothly and quickly
um the idea that one of the ideas that
I'm working on or have been asked the
researcher not not the committee
researcher but the actual like OLS
researchers is to find
um how Seattle did their um
did their accepting of plans and
approving of plans like regionally or or
at the state level
um and so I have have already asked
about that
um and was planning on
um trying to get some language for it
for the committee on that
um they gave me information that was
kind of
off to the side of that not exactly what
I was looking for and so I don't have
that for you guys today all I have is
this other Amendment which is is
um
trying to help
allow more municipality or to to have
kind of the effect of uh
um allowing more
encouraging municipalities to improve
their processes
um or improve their regulations to be
um more
accepting of you know
smaller lot sizes and smaller structures
without going down the road of that um
that some on this committee oppose which
is mandating it from the state level and
this this amendment
to HB 313 that I've I've drafted of two
two three five H
um is essentially incentivizing them by
tying it to the housing appeals board
which or not the housing housing
Champion designation which we just
um created inside of the budget and
saying that if you need if you want to
become a housing champion and get the
money that might come with that
then you would need to
um have not unreasonable lot size
requirements and or actually very very
um
good lot size requirements for housing
and um and then municipality shall not
require minimum sizes for structures now
that we have this new
um small uh
small structure
um uh zoning or not uh building code and
so that would not this would not be a
mandate it would just be if they wanted
to become be considered for the housing
Champion they would need to do this and
so I felt like this was
um kind of a way to
encourage them uh okay without doing the
Mandate so so let me yeah to there's a
housing Champion designation that has
been created through the budget
um currently the rulemaking process to
be a housing Champion is up to
um which office of is Bea yeah yeah Bea
so this this amendment would just
clarify some of the rules that are the
law something you would like to be
required in order to be a housing
Champion so this is a completely opt-in
program right housing okay so I I see no
problem with this it's an odd it's
opt-in it's further clarifying the
legislature is giving some guidance to
Bea
um with this but does anybody on the
committee have anything to say about
this amendment representative McConkey
thank you I'm unfamiliar with the um the
language and I'd like to see the
language for that
um perhaps you could educate me a little
under uh line 10.
for properties they're not connected
Municipal Water and Sewer lines adopt
adopt adoption of minimum lot size no
greater than double the required septic
radius for four bedroom septic system
should be based on soil type
I'm completely unfamiliar and I don't
know if something was meant to be in
there to say well radius is for four
bedroom but the required septic radius
radius is not a term that's used
um
for the determination of
environmental
rules and regulations subsurface
ws-1000 so perhaps you know something
thank you thank you I was trying to so
um on the plans there's a well there's a
septic radius and a well radius that
like I guess can't intersect or
something like that
um maybe you'd be more familiar with
that but there is an actual radius
usually drawn on the
on the maps right I maybe it's a Well
radius that that the septic can't be
within or something like that um can you
be sure yeah is there a way to better
write that sentence well I I'd like I'd
like to see where it came out of but so
if you are creating a new subdivision
and
um you would you would designate that
and it was under five acres you would
designate an area as part of the
subdivision requirement that there was
at least a four thousand square foot
area that a septic system could go into
so you you put that on your plan
so anyone buying a lot that's less than
five acres knows that they can put a
septic system and they can buy it
without a design they already know what
happens then on top of that you would
have a well radius which would be for a
simple house up to five bedrooms would
be 75
footwell radius which works out to be uh
0.41 Acres
um
they they don't necessarily the way this
um and I I'm not I'm just saying that
needs to be reworked and the the well
the septic radius is is not a term
that's used it's it depends on how good
your soil is or how bad your soil is how
many square foot of space you need
and then
if you're willing to do what is still
somewhat conventional systems you don't
need all the four thousand square feet
you may only need a thousand square feet
so
um I I don't think you're getting what
thank you
um what I'm trying to do mainly with
this is is to
Thai
um the needs for water and septic
and the soil type
to
um
all combined
and say that that size
um let's say double that size
requirement is the minimum
is the maximum minimum that a
municipality could put
and be considered for housing Champion
designation and so I'm trying to
um get away encourage the municipalities
to get away from the two-acre
thing and say okay we're going to you
know base it off of you know Des says
we're going to need this much for septic
and we're going to need this much for
um water let's say and and
um and then the municipality can go
above and beyond that but not more than
double that or something like that and
that would be the minimum
because after all we've we've stated
before that it's all about help the
purpose of zoning is about health and
safety and so the double is you know I
think the the
you know what I'm trying to go for as
like the flexibility of you know health
and safety versus you know preference
and then that would be if you go above
that then you're not really a housing
Champion you're just a regular
municipality seems like such a special
program
so is there a way that
um yeah that's what I was trying to go
for so if I if you have language or if
you have a better sentence for
representing if if the um if the um
representative could send me the
language or someone send me the language
that's required to be a part of this
program and I'm more than happy to see
if I can help you craft that to to meet
what you want so in the in the programs
in its very infant stages so I think
this is a good time to provide some
additional guidance I I we're leaving a
lot of the discretion up to Bea
um but if we want to provide like some
guidance I think that would be important
um representative yokella then
representative yeah um so so the only
language right now there is no language
for the housing designation yet because
it hasn't officially become I don't
think it's um in enacted yet I mean it
depends if we if the governor signed the
budget and you know if if they're the
enacting Clause has gone into effect so
I don't think that they've built
anything so all I'm doing is just adding
to a different
um so the only
only requirements right now are a
through d
in this uh uh RSA 12071 Roman 3. so a
through D and then I'm just adding e f
and g to say you know when you're doing
these requirements they have to include
these things otherwise they they
wouldn't be qualified
Mr chairman
um not to uh belabor the point but if I
can see what's a through D I think your
uh your statement f
um
and E and G is probably perfectly fine
okay so action item representative
yokella I'm letting you take that
representative Reed thank you and this
is just a first of all I'd like to thank
representative for working on this
because I wholeheartedly agree and
um and appreciate the work here
um I know that we heard in presentation
that according to the technology
available that there were Technologies
available that would even further reduce
the the footage requirement
um might there not be language in here
that ties That to the to say that the
municipality shall allow because I
understand that they don't allow a lot
of those Technologies but the
municipality shall allow those
Technologies and tie the minimum to what
that technology would like it could
still be twice of whatever the
requirement but what that technology
so that'd be something to think about
therapy thank you for the suggestion
I'll I will be considering that thank
you
guys
so reasonable parking requirements I
know we identified
down and streamline I'm on commercials
I mean does anyone else worked on
streamlining Municipal I guess yeah I'm
looking at is there anything that we've
heard from our presentations about
streamlining Municipal inspections that
we think that we could
um
help clarify or this committee could
look at and is there anybody that wants
to take that on or look at what the
inspection process is for municipalities
and how we can
okay um representative Walsh can you
just give us an outline of
the inspection process
yeah I was just going to suggest um
because I did talk about this a few
times and I thought it was one of the
things we could certainly all agree on
it's just for it helps everybody to
streamline these these approvals and I
had a conversation with somebody else
too uh and I have not verified it yet
whether or not the current housing
appeals board can even hear situations
of appeals from say fire or or building
codes
um I don't I'm not prepared to speak too
much in detail but I certainly think it
deserves a subcommittee to try to come
up to some answers yeah so I think you
stepped out of the room we went so
number two
um we're getting language from a former
chair of the hab who can
um
subject suggest clarifying a language
that would allow so I'm looking at on
the memo to C and looking at adding all
of these is like reasons you could
appeal and we'll have that mirror that
language mirrored in the
um land you socket that we also just
passed so that it's kind of two
different Avenues
um and we can clarify that how they're a
ruling from the State Fire Marshal or
Etc that could be
um appealed there so maybe that would
help solve some of that
and streamline it yeah the only concern
is we may hear if we we keep specifying
more
responsibilities to that they may not
have the Manpower I don't know what
their docket looks like currently so it
is a concern but it's worth looking into
okay so we're gonna get some we're gonna
get some language so I'll I'll be the
point person on that and I'll be able to
all right so
I'm looking at the rest of these
right here on the memo is there anything
that anybody would like to discuss
further down so
impact fees building code or via review
I mean I'm intrigued by
did we are I'm sorry I kind of blanked
out we were already covering the
expansion of commercially to include
um is that already being taken care of
by somebody no I I don't know if I would
be in favor of that but I would like to
at least see language on that okay
um I Kristen also put together a memo on
impact fees I don't think
you printed you printed like half and on
all of it so we also have an opportunity
to designate that a certain amount of
impact fees goes towards
some funding mechanism and municipality
is that something that anybody
wanted to look further into
because some municipalities charge it
some don't so maybe we could say if you
do charge it it goes towards you know
what should the impact fees go ahead
just put it back on
thank you Mr chairman most of the impact
fees are already designated for
something like schools fire and things
like that and I think that's already
being done as far as designations
okay I didn't know if we wanted to make
it more targeted or leave it flexible I
mean I I don't think it's fair for them
to charge in fact fees uh on smaller
units that you know aren't going to have
any children but the schools also have
that impact feat so they want to build a
building with a bunch of efficiency
apartments and they're going to require
me to pay a school fee you know you know
there's no kids going to live there you
know that's something we could look into
represent Damon or my apartment home
we might want to look at newer research
on
School utilization because Public School
enrollment has declined so much
there's a threshold we're increasing the
number of children attending schools is
not increasing cost because you're not
needing greater facilities or greater
staff
and I think there is some preliminary
research on that maybe out of Yukon
um but that should be incorporated into
that there or could be incorporated it
representative
[Music]
um
if if I remember correctly the impact
fees are designated for a specific
purpose so if they were if they were for
um school and that school
um and have to be
um
and if they're not used then they would
be returned to the
to the people that um
that paid them right so if they if those
those P that development that the
representative was talking about did not
have an impact wouldn't the money just
be returned or you're trying to
um
reduce the cost of that borrowing of
that money or is there any is there any
way I think developers indicated that
impact fees are an impediment towards
development so is there any way to
create language that would allow is
there anything stopping Miss Pally from
allowing 20 years to pay the impact fee
instead of one year or
um could we
you know say that
a developer or somebody that makes a it
creates a proposal
um
may ask for a 10-year payment plan
instead of a one year I don't know how
the committee feels about that I think
that would be a good idea because that
does stop people
I mean the guy from Riddle was a good
example of what what he was saying and
agonized too and it's a lot of sort of
upfront money it can spread it out and
even maybe charge interest or something
well they're making payments it would
help people get in help people get
started bring down the cost of the
construction is what we're looking at so
um my resident planning board member is
um representative Walsh is there
anything required um
prohibiting a municipality from doing
that now or do you think there could be
language put in there that would clarify
that they're allowed to a developer can
request that or municipality is allowed
to do it so I understand you your
question correctly as far as I know it's
upfront money I don't know of any
mechanism or tool for them to stretch it
out I will also say as being part of a
town that that does impose impact fees I
cannot tell you an example where any
money was returned uh it's just when you
see and I'm not targeting anybody but
whether it's fire school or whatever the
budgets go up every year anyway so it's
so long as budgets are going up based on
and development's going up there's a
justification for the money to disappear
so do we need enabling language that
would allow municipality I got your
representative that would allow
municipality to charge impact fees for
20 years instead of one year yeah if you
want to take that as an angle uh I can
see that the legitimate legitimacy of
that we would need language you can't do
it right now as far as I know yep okay I
will um
does any I don't mind working on that as
somebody else or unless somebody else
really so chopping at the bit
representative Reed specifically that's
what Manchester was requesting was a
20-year return I believe we currently
have a requirement for a six-year return
um so just to clarify so we expand um
sixth year to 20 year
representative yokello so representative
was talking about how how fast you have
to return the money
um
what I'm
thinking about as you talk about like oh
being able to collect you know some
amount of money let's say a hundred
thousand dollars over
um you know 20 years or whatever
um
the mechanism for that for someone that
is building the property and then
selling the property
um it would seem like that would need to
be as par like part of the deed or
whatever that they're supposed to be you
know payments and the amount of you know
you know you know one thousand dollars
per per month until you know such date
you know 2027 or whatever the case may
be being in the deed or something like
that I don't know how you would do that
while if the person sells it to the
weeds I think all we need to do is go in
and say if you want to you can charge
this and then they have to figure that
out we don't have to clarify that for
them yeah and if somebody's building it
and selling it it could be part of the
sales agreement that that's paid during
the sale but that'll be between the
developer municipality and the buyer
uh representative Walsh yeah
I'm all set I had the same questions uh
representative okay no thank you just
for clarity just so I'm clear too I must
I must have misunderstood you it is
correct it's upfront money now and
you've got six years to use it uh before
you have to give it back my point is
I've never seen it given back because
the budgets keep climbing every year and
that money uh from the impact fees is
part of it so
so I thought you were looking at a way
to reduce The Upfront money yes that's
what I was expecting we were mixing two
things so
I want to put in enabling language that
would allow municipality to charge
impact fees for an extended period of
time at a at a smaller rate and then
allow charge reasonable interest or
something
on it if a developer if that agreement
is reached between misspelling developer
so I'll send language over but is there
anybody that's totally against that idea
nobody okay we're gonna work on that
did you have something representative I
would just say on um thinking through if
it's a larger development that the
impact fees would only be by whatever
phase they're in and if a unit if it's a
unit should be sold then you should
consider that unit when it sold that
money has to be paid okay and try and
keep out of making people Bond you know
the total number because that becomes
all right
as far as number eight the pre-approval
for multi-family housing developments
that meet fire safety design and health
standards
would that be according to our national
standard
um or a regional standard or a state
standard because I'm thinking of more of
like a plug and play type Building
Development so how would how would that
why it's good
um representative color
so if
um as I was kind of talking about before
I was looking into kind of the
pre-approval for the Adu and Seattle's
situation but what I'm what I am
envisioning is not something that was
limited to adus but limited is is
available for you know people that do 3D
houses or do construction off-site that
might that
um
you know the pl those the blocks that
that fit together all these different
kind of designs that that are being
produced
um should be able to go to what I'm
thinking as either the regional Planning
Commission or something like that and
they would go through kind of the
approval process instead of at the local
level they would do it at the regional
or the state level and they would go
through kind of the exact same process
that they would do at the local level
except Joe is do it at the state level
and then it would just be approved for
all kind of the subdivisions below that
and then they would have to kind of go
separately for you know the footings and
the drainage and all of that stuff for
that specific site so that's kind of
what I have envisioned
um
um so it would be at the
I guess to answer your question it would
be
at these
state level
and and obviously it would have to be
allowed in all of the
the levels I guess
it would have to be allowed like that
type of building would have to be
allowed I guess in all like you wouldn't
be able to build something that's not
prohibited by a federal law right that
would be
that would be weird okay
is there
specific language that we can put
together so I'm thinking I'm happy to do
the sub subcommittee on it I I tried to
get language but I have not got the the
like how did they actually do this you
know receiving of the of the plans
approval of the plans and how did they
um work that in with these other kind of
plans for the you know the drainage and
the footings and all of that stuff how
did all of that interplay and other
municipality or end of their states or
whoever has also done that
um so I wasn't able to
create anything yet but I have the
researcher you know the OLS researchers
looking for that language and then I
plan on developing it yeah over the over
the would you like to put together a
small committee on that to look into
that and I'm I'm act yeah that's fine
okay is would you like to be a part of
that okay so representative Lorenzo
representative can you guys work
together I'll have you chair it
representative okay call call a meeting
before the first week of September so
that we can kind of get some language
um get just okay
okay so you just like I said you need 24
hours to call a meeting so okay does
anybody else want to be a part of it
I have a question um I'm gonna
representative McConkey then
representative
so um I I like what you're you're going
for there I believe during the
conversation when we talked about
um 3D but modular in manufactured
housing that already has a standard that
meets fire safety design and health
standards
if if you're Pro and you're going to see
more and more of that and I've seen in
some of those cities you're talking
about infill and so forth so I I think
you I think you're you're going to find
that you're going to need some sort of
federal standard that's accepted whether
it's the HUD seal or whatever it is and
and I totally agree and then at that
point when we in rural areas when when
um
um a GC modulars and that sort of thing
so the plans when they go the building
department stamps are already on and the
review stops and then we come back now
to what where it's going to be on site
and Zoning so I think it's a great idea
and uh but I think you're going to have
to tie it to some higher providing it
meets that standard you you move forward
quicker
so he's saying start at the federal
level
and work your way down is that correct
yeah so when I when I the pre-approval
for multi-family Housing Development
meets Federal safety uh Health standards
I think you're going to find to do that
you're going to need some higher
certification or this or the state
develops what that standard is but well
I I think it'd be valuable to connect
with Ben frost on this because he'll
probably have an idea of that stuff so
maybe he's probably listening right now
so
then wherever you are shoot us an email
I have a question I think representative
Gibbs might be interested in that aspect
okay so
um
I would be happy if you'd like to reach
out we'll put her on that committee as
well okay representative Reed I have a
question and I think we loosened
requirements
um for remote meetings of this sort not
public hearings but no so would we not
be able to do a subcommittee remotely
over the summer no it's just um it's
it's state boards okay all right
um I if we're done with that like number
uh eight I would like to bring up number
seven
I I would love to see something but I'm
you know not willing to just do it all
on my own but I would love to see
something that
um above you know whatever to allow tiny
homes or small starter homes more
affordable homes
um I would love to see something along
those minimum square footage
requirements the minimum square footage
requirements so that towns cannot say
you have to build something over 2 000
is there
I it depends on
me personally it depends on what that
square footage looks like before I could
personally get on board with it so
um what about does everybody I would
kick in my ideas around on that too I'm
okay kicking the ideas around I just
don't want to make it too too onerous on
I want to give them the flexibility
as much as possible you have a number in
mind you have too many too many with
lights on
too many people with lights on I don't
have a number I don't have a number in
mind
okay
answer the question does anybody have
any number representative color
um so obviously my my amendment that I
already talked about HP into HB 13 or
313 already was kind of
trying to get them to adopt uh
a good
standard
um are you talking about kind of doing
the opposite and saying hey if you don't
want to be a housing Champion you can't
have a lot requirement of a hundred
acres and a building size requirement of
one thousand square feet minimum
what if we just Loop that language into
this housing Champion stuff so that way
it's not a requirement but if you want
to be a housing Champion you can't
require more than this amount in a
single family zoned area
does that make sense why don't we add
the square foot into the
housing Champion language clarification
well isn't the hair square foot
you have a lot
line 15.
shall not require minimum sizes for
structures good point it's already done
okay so then
that's what I was going for so okay that
makes sense I mean to be fair I kind of
like so many of the ideas out of the 313
that we've talked about I kind of just
want to make them their own bills for
towns but I understand you want to be
nice to the towns I mean I'm happy with
doing a bill you know I'm I'm happy with
co-sponsoring your bill to mandate all
of this but I'm also want this to pass
so I I want that's why I have this bill
well again representative Yokel is the
voice of reason
um does anybody have any would you like
to contribute on on that one that yeah
if you added into the housing Champion
it I don't I'm I'm intrigued about the
housing Champion thing I have no
objection to that I just did I just did
want to mention a reality and when if we
start looking at lot sizes and house
sizes and I don't even think we have a
lot minimum I mean a house size minimum
we might uh and it's we did a study
about 15 years ago I didn't bother going
to get it uh because the numbers are so
far outdated now but believe it or not
it in hooks that we established the
planning department did it on their own
um because this obviously what we're
debating now has been talked about for
free for decades
there is actually a threshold in the
value of a home where it actually the
revenues taken in from the property are
actually black and a little bit of a
bonus to the town and below that
threshold if I remember correctly for
every dollar taken in Revenue it costs a
town a dollar Seventeen to provide all
the services so I mean these are
realities that are there and it's some
of the pushback you're going to get if
we start going down the road of moving
of the bar if you will just those and
I'm sure we're not the only Town that's
actually has looked at this before so I
would see that probably that
in this language in the housing the
housing Champion certification if you
want to if you want to provide
additional guidance the the mandating on
municipalities I'd like to stay away
from as much as possible but if you
would like to put that bill into I'm
sure you will so go ahead I mean we we
kind of talked about like we were
talking about the um
the commercially zoned
um residential stuff I was I was
considering just adding one of these
things in here
um into this housing Champion that said
that um that they allow residential by
right in all the zones and that would
qualify them for the housing Champion
thing too also and so that we
we can we can reach that happy place
again with that that um
instead of uh because it sounded like
you were not not in favor of the
mandating it but but maybe as part of
the housing Champion thing you would be
fine with it so
I I feel like this this uh idea is a
winner
great representative Reed I just wanna
for the record clarify that if I were to
work on language to mandate towns that I
would be more nuanced than simply saying
no structure minimum sizes I would say
like maybe areas that were tiny home
friendly for example but you know I
would I would do more than just say
nothing
so um
I have I have I'll put this all together
in an email so number one representative
Reed you're the point person for this I
don't see us needing yep I don't see us
needing to talk about this until the
first week of September number two I'll
be the point person I'll connect with um
the housing appeals board people and
make sure we can get language that would
expand the appeal process to allow for
um on unfair or or unreasonable or
perceived unreasonable
um rulings by state or local Health fire
um or Heritage commission Des all these
things allow people process through the
hab or the Circuit Court
the land review docket number three
representative McConkey is going to send
us language on
um Des
um who was looking into that Municipal
inspections
or you're looking into so do we not want
to touch that right now
I didn't take no
um
I mean Municipal inspections my thing
was kind of the pre-approval thing it's
a little bit of streamlining the process
because then if it was pre-approved then
you wouldn't have to right so we'll
probably we'll combine that with the
pre-approval and I'll foreign
Delorenzo representative Gibbs on that
um
number six we've dealt with
number seven square footage requirement
we're dealing with in the um housing
Champion language and then number nine
impact fees I'll put together some
language on
um allowing a municipality to extend the
impact fees over a certain amount of
time
um and charge reasonable interest and
administrative fees so that will allow a
developer the flexibility of paying
those upfront or
um spreading it out over a 20 up to
20-year process
okay
is there anything else that we need to
talk about before we break for the
summer
did I miss you saying who's doing the
follow-up on impact fees that's me
yep I'll take care of that
representative we didn't
um we didn't really talk about the D.O.T
um standard stuff did we
is anyone did
did we skip that on purpose or are we
um is anyone interested in that I guess
yeah I didn't understand
um I didn't remember that conversation
as well as I probably should I think
that there was a conversation that a
developer made about how
there need to be two sidewalks or
something on a road I think that they
were suggesting that
um
that d e d o t has some
guidance that often is just adopted
wholesale at the local level
um and for inappropriate roads
like you know a cul-de-sac or something
being
built to you know Highway standards
essentially
um right and just because it was adopted
wholesale
um at the at the local level and maybe
um
trying to find some lower level
recommendations for that
um for those side or ancillary streets
that municipalities or encourage them to
adopt you know lower standards for those
ancillary streets instead of the highway
standards so I think that is something
that we can Loop in with the hab and say
if if you disagree with
that guidance for that specific
area you can appeal it
through the hab
you know representative Washington yeah
thank you if I remember right that was
kind of an afterthought from The God Who
giving us the presentation that day I
think it was even during the question
and answer period that's fine we can
look at it uh I'll even take a look at
it as far as our requirements I don't
know what other towns are doing
but the reason they do make it easy and
I'm sure it's not interstate highway
standards that they're applying
um but that you know after a subdivision
is built the town actually has to take
ownership of that road and that includes
maintenance and replacing it and so
that's why you see the the towns going
with a pretty strict standardized so I
don't know how much we want to look into
it but but I'll take a piece and they
have to plow it and they want room for
the fire engines to go up and be able to
turn around so they're a chance
and keep in mind it's not just a
pavement either with all your substrates
a lot of these with curbs and sidewalks
now that you've got structures
underneath I mean there's a lot to it so
okay representative Reed uh tangentially
I would ask that representative viokella
consider for his uh housing Champions
313 to add or just consider adding a
piece about walkability and bicycle uh
that why are you looking like that
that kind of thing that towns can
provide makes
um housing more livable more housing
more livable for people
so it's it's just something to consider
and we can consider things without the
faces
representative Walsh
well if we're considering things because
I know we're looking at affordability
especially in terms of Apartments but I
did get a call this morning from
somebody who was just appointed to the
electric vehicle charging station in
apartment study committee that's going
on so are we looking at affordable
apartments as a goal or are we going to
start mandating electric vehicle
charging stations too because their
suggestion was should this committee's
topic come to this committee and I said
I don't know but it's a good question
well I yeah I mean I live in a townhouse
I don't I don't I don't have a garage I
have no if I want an electric vehicle I
wouldn't even know where to put it
I don't own that spot either so
um okay do you wanna do you want to look
further into the the um planning
requirements on dot standards
representative Walsh all right all right
so does that cover everyone
um everyone in the committee I'll send
I'll send an email in the next day or
two that'll kind of outline everything
we talked about today
is there anything else that anyone would
like to look at
representative Damon
I don't think anybody took the updating
the building code I could do some
background work on that to see what
happens appreciate anybody's input who
knows more than I which is everything I
believe it's a rule making process I
think there's a new code coming out this
year there was a seven there's a code in
17 right and it's just not even said 17
or 18.
so the uh legislature formalized the
building code and other codes updated
update process uh I think it was last
year
um they you all I think finished
tweaking that process so essentially for
the building code there's the building
code review board they look at
um the codes come out every three years
um so the state is currently the 2018
codes our initial codes are 2015.
they're looking at the 2021 codes
a new code will be coming out from the
international code
um people but uh the State Building Code
review board is looking at the 2021
codes suggesting changes
um and then that kind of an
administrative process continues there
will have to be a adoption via vote of
the legislature for any updates to that
code but presumably it'll be
mostly the same as the 2021 codes
International codes but with some
state-specific tweaks
and I can certainly put you in contact
with the people who would know way more
about that than I do yeah Bill McKinney
who presented to us probably would be
your best point of contact for that and
I'm happy to send or nature can send you
his contact information
he's the chair of the state New
Hampshire boa or yeah
yes yep okay represent Walsh yeah and
the fire codes work the same way or
similarly
nfpa1 is a National Standard we adopt it
with our own exceptions
after the fact usually we were just on
18 I believe and we might have moved up
all right we have all of our chores for
the summer so I hope everybody has a
good summer and gets much needed break
from the legislature as I will
representative Damon
so just planning ahead it sounds like we
will have a committee meeting in the
first week of September plan the first
week of September is that meaning Labor
Day week that is what
what are you laughing about
oh yeah no I I I really don't have an
intention of doing it the day after
Labor Day but
um because filing the filing period is
the second week of September
so it starts September 11th right
okay so Labor day is the fourth yeah the
filing period starts the Monday after
late in the legislation the legislature
isn't where you're going to meet so we
have flexibility for Wednesday or
Thursdays to get together I'm pretty
sure there's going to be other committee
tonight
thank you everyone have a good summer